[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation it's time
for Echo episode three this is Coy this
is John we don't really have much time
we got to film this right now so leave a
like on this video subscribe and click
the notification Bell thank you so much
and pre for helping us set down these
highlights F length through your watch
res sing with your own copy of echo for
super sex rejects over our patreon page
we cover several things SC through the
highlights and watch alongs included I
don't even care to ask you how you guys
are doing let's get to it
[Music]
cool Martin scorsi
presents he's been fighting to get into
this universe in the late 1800s Indian
country was infested with dangerous
criminals threatening the safety of the
native nations tribes established their
own police force to bring these
criminals to
Justice these trip is this like a lawn
Defenders the light Horsemen all
right wow this is fun is this fun this
story of what they had to endure yeah
the style is fun
CG history can be light and
badass it's fun oh my God what do those
gourds ever do to you I love how this is
shot so modern day with cool camera work
a lot of depth of field
yeah
oo
[Music]
too wow cool all right now let's see you
do that with the vibranium Shield or
your
hat uhoh but it's in the
name yeah something shouldn't change
ever men are life
takers just produce a baby and then let
it be unto the
elements braids are for men it's right I
agree if it wasn't difficult to do with
headphones on I'd tie one right
now you will defeat the
[Music]
Predator this a really cool way to do a
backstory an exposition and I like how
much time they take for these things
yeah they're letting everything breathe
especially the openings being the
supernatural or past elements yeah going
from the the game and the last one to
this oh man she going to save the day
she going to whoop some ass right now I
think they're chronological too right
the mountain falling the game and then
this seem to
[Music]
be
whoa bang
bang some ass tcko this must be oh she's
the ancestor that yeah beautiful
shots whoa we have Ender full frame here
dang and a color fade
in
Cory
uhoh and some sound design
get
[Music]
him aim
true braer for men take that down at
[Music]
once ah just that look in her
eye proud papa she can
shoot nice I like that the sound I
didn't even catch the frame change and
the sound like blending into it that was
really cool I want to say you said frame
change it actually went frame change t t
it was 4 by what six as Zack Snider
intended
yeah Ah that's a great first shot
after that is that is clever I really
like film making is on is
really this and what if have really
demonstrated film making capacity in
Marvel more than some other thing agreed
it's called Cinema SC
ASI
oh
Cinema C the crap I didn't come here to
get laid up by some old res dog like res
dogs ah you used to melt like butter
when I talk
you Marvel
Spotlight my back kill the mood thought
that might have something to do with it
want to
hump she's too much like her father you
don't know that you don't even know her
and you do you haven't seen her any more
than I have in the last 20
years uh water hump you know you two are
exactly alike we are not alike you lost
your daughter what should just swallow
your pride before you lose your
granddaughter too I can't talk to her
now I got nothing to say oh you find
something well maybe you shouldn't talk
to her maybe you should just listen for
once you know what it is that I figured
out of why I'm so connected more with
the supporting characters because
there's some actual like tension in a
variety of emotion whether that be like
fear and joy there's levels MH or with
whenever we cut to Maya sometimes I feel
like it's kind of she's just little one
note being B
yeah Zane I promise you man my is here
tonight have already wait for my call oh
trackx Mafia coming to town let's get
bowling alley fight or rolling skate
fight
that's meanwhile an evil dead
rise now this is where uh Ben Affleck
and galado had a conversation about
steeping wol oh
yeah
oh
cool they
mean
o oh they tried to warn her get you with
mystical chloroform no this I think she
was really taken no she the spirits the
ancestors are trying to prot Spirits do
it
it's fast oh you're going to have to
fight on that leg
now that it is a
blessing
bag read
lips can't you guys I'll take care of it
argue in Sign Language guys yes consider
it
uhoh oh he's he's he must be maybe he's
not bad maybe not or maybe he's going to
do something treacherous I don't know I
hope not he's in a tough
position budy oh no she's going to be in
danger and she's going to realize how
much she cares about her oh
man
hello shut up shut up oh boy you guys
gonna make this
personal get out of really want to
escape I'll do whatever it takes to
skate oh no we didn't think to lock this
door the delivery door it's after 600 PM
no was supposed to be there thought it
was
fun hey hey I tried the front whoa not a
good time pretty busy I like the timing
of
I won't take very long I maybe you guys
can communicate in Sign Language there
you go there you go why don't you call
me tomorrow the rank's being um audited
by the IRS and I'm just swimming in
paperwork is there anything I can do no
no no I'm good probably shouldn't have
deducted all that mileage on all those
pairs of
skates that's clever joke they'll give
you 22 cents a gallon appreciate it I
thought these guys were working for fist
they work for for the IRS yeah yeah
that's the twist tracksuit Mafia is
actually Auditors I'm having the hardest
time keeping up with the
show you can't spell Wilson Fisk without
the
IRS come on get your firefighting hose
yes
down dispatch dispatch oh no there's a
third one way to go Maya the people you
care about are in danger now because of
you you're going to realize this episode
that you care Oh is she going to attach
that skate to her left
oh my God she's going to take him on one
legged the reunion you want you should
have said
hi that shirt
though this better be like in a
impactful ass moment the whole MCU have
been waiting for Bonnie and her to
reunite they also can't communicate
because their hands are Ted she could
take off her shoe Morris
code sweet
the name's B of course of course like
how we just like cut
through
non not
just woo great shot that's really cool
that's a cool way of using that Trope of
reflection in
Mirror another great example of like a
filmmaker like it feels like planned and
storyboarded whoa whoa
not get carried away here
pre-production okay thank you show I
needed this scene with
her yeah me Greg Greg me
feeling I wrote you every day for 5
years a
letter she's no gosl they just feel like
sisters
yeah yeah it's you got to try not to
keep touch nowadays what did you do Maya
brought this on herself coming home all
I did was accelerate the process you
called someone I ain't taking orders no
more not from you I'm taking orders from
someone else with money sometimes he's
got better
orders come on Vicky I swear I heard
something it might be loose quickly
though
some
ADR way she holding that gun
yeah the both of them
jeez thank you whoa whoa whoa whoa don't
shoot her if she's dead when they get
here we ain't getting paid hey eyes on
the prize this is our fault we letting
him do the tie in hey hey do not
assum un kill them yeah take them
out oh
yeah y'all ain't ready for this come
on [__] they locked it we can't shoot
through the door I think we got to go
back in there and H Tire it's not worth
the trouble the door's locked
anyway what is that phone number can I
like climb through like the ceiling like
die hard it a little bit you know what I
mean the window got a plan she's going
to pop out she would have R Bonnie
without and can Maya not read lips I'm
sure she can right but whenever they cut
to her perspective and people are
talking it seems like she can't make out
what they're saying you're the guy then
yeah I'm the guy Vicki Vicki's my name I
hope the information you've been texting
is legit I don't like being played with
guaranteed it's the real deal assuming
you brought that money oh yeah no we got
protocols right package first you don't
look like walk in with the money do you
bro of course not he really does look
like Evan Peters Bo
over oh my God she's macgyvering her
foot she's going to put him on her
hands whoa she is
Crafty they've given her a lot of time
to put something together she's making
her own Johnny
[Music]
Five the shots of her yes
like very pleased with her abilities
this is Herby Origins guys we're getting
the Fantastic Four robot she's building
it my have built this in a store
room
scr nice that was great John that was
really guys thank you I I really
app please smash like And
subscribe that's R Us
come on now don't I like that detail of
the glass just residing
in shooting her with bearings that's
great oh my
God this poor woman she's not cut out
for this no she's earned it how you get
jammed up like
this you got something to spill huh this
guy's having fun by Lopez Lopez who blew
up the Armory we're actually not at
Liberty to say until we get our money
yep you're going to get killed man I
love the way he's playing that
too grasping for any threat of authority
in this
situation God it looks like a saw trap
how about let's all go out and you show
me that one the cat brothers let's all
go out think he wants to go out take him
out oh
boy oh dude
dude yeah Evan Holbrook I actually
really love that
detail thanks again VY for the odd tip
how he like jumped and got shot like
that result where is Maya Lopez she's
coming for you take them all out in this
yes bur to the witch SL first zombie in
the
M oh I'm so
excited even this expression like she's
coming oh my God yeah the lighting in
this place was designed for a fight
Batman and Robin
fights yes linoln Park music videos can
he fight I guarantee it I mean it looks
kind of like a Rob Zombie music video to
be
fair with the needle
drop oo
nice bit of a slow motion to that yeah
yeah he can't have the Daredevil team on
every fight
SC what why did you think little Tiffany
deserved to
die make America SK
again
[Music]
ooh d Dam oh yes you are your
people interesting genetic memory but
with powers well I think it's like
mirror in the
trajectory I think it's
both
nice
ah the pinball
machine that was cool ooh Legends of the
coyote whoa some jump frames are
interesting like a zap Zack Snider esque
like zoom
out cool cool cool oh Cosmic claw these
overhead shots
settings she always looks like she's
having like a great time fighting yeah
she's always so happy
after
yes
nice got to the whip oh that's so good
beautiful it's like Jackie Chan with a
horseshoe I love seeing props use
environmental props ski ball oh use
everything at your disposal oh my
God come on come on put his head through
the little hole with this a th000 points
not
Bonnie mystical power
[Music]
time I haven't heard this song In
Forever it's going to be Kingpin yep I
have one eye I
I I thought yeah I understand I'm sorry
I let me just nope
[Music]
I love watching this guy let's go
wow okay leave my surate daughter alone
yeah even from New York there is a
certain calibration to that Nick of Time
suspense you got to hit though and uh
but they didn't timing is is a little
funky here and there on on this show I
think yeah but cool fight I like how the
fight distinguished itself from the last
fight yeah Rob Zombie got that Marvel
money
[Music]
yeah I do like the dynamic this creates
for her yeah we get to see her open up
some and they do see like sisters like
immediate oh the
touch unless I need to punch you for a
diversion again I will hurt you they
will not hurt you I will hurt
[Music]
you yeah I think they need to kill off
Bonnie the only thing that's keeping her
human Bonnie needs to get an Iron Man
suit or something or become a you know a
special thing I they need a fridge body
part the part where we were kidnapped by
the guy who cleans my
skate
who do you think that was only one
person who could have and he has one
eye well you didn't shoot him in the
face good enough tonight things caught
up to us both if the offer still stands
I'm helping still stands they stand oh
dude I really like him a lot that guy a
lot yeah he's great and she's opening up
because of these relationships in a way
I hoped they would that's why I wanted
to hold back some of
my yeah because I feel like ma is so
much more invested in this episode also
why it's a good binge like I do feel
like the model was good for this
definitely designed for a bench I think
Disney's on the right path here or the
show's just complete utter [__]
according to what everyone said before
oh yeah those leaks from those
incredible
source so lovely music
c yeah
oh my God we got some mystical [__] for
you that's cool it's it's a McGuffin I
love him so much he's great you uh don't
uh like
it she doesn't know what it
is that
means Chuck tushka is on the scene ooh
if you you uh don't uh like it I could
paint it matte
black that that's the first time we've
really seen a full smile yeah is it yeah
she smirked but that was like a grin
that was a very real moment now as a man
I'm invested in her hey oh it's she
looked nicer if she smiled more just
came
true
yeah who that's cool chocked off
forever don't get in family business
since your uh grandmother and I not
together no more I still try to
hump
daily you won't go see her
yeah she does her heart is broken when
you let
she left this place like it was like a
museum preserve you in
time yeah you're one to talk about
reaching sounds familiar there Maya I
guess we all do things we wish were
different Disney's often saying the same
[Laughter]
thing yeah that's why they reshoot
everything boy it's on a really good
path I think each episode has been
getting better yeah and its unique voice
is becoming more and more into
Focus man this shot so well God damn
yeah it doesn't feel like a product like
it feels like a show like there's so
much like heart in you could tell that
people loved making it in a really
interesting way there is a passion
behind the camera
here like the shots all have flourish
and Beauty yeah like they really
utilizer City and
locations and I I
do feel it feels very much lived in the
Cho to people of what how they utilize
it here in their story just the way they
spend time with and on them in both
small character moments and the big like
sweeping flashbacks like I just love
that shot of that grandmother just the
difference between shooting on location
versus the volume but to scale like this
all feels like the difference between
like practical and having people that
are invested behind the camera on camera
oh 1 million
per. mystical
ending we a Fisk ending a mystical Fisk
ending I have one
eye oh she's in like superhero Garb now
yeah Echo Red look at them
straps strapped up there he is nail back
like
a I sensed his
[Music]
presence I like the tune they compose
for him was that in Hawkeye or is this
new I feel new I think it's heavy it's
strong just feels like it's being played
on a broken instrument
yeah
oh come to Papa yes that was awesome I
love the boldness of Fisk showing up
like that without anyone else just him
being
enormous enormous in such a vulnerable
stage like she could just shoot him in
the other eye she want to and and she he
just comes up injured and like clearly
hurt yeah at a new outfit looking fresh
with those drips oh my man that was I
really like this show kick up pick up on
the dialogue whoa what what dialogue
what do you have for me what the drips
coin oh we're on the drips do it John
we're on the
drips you can't oh John just mocking
what he does now do what you naturally
do I'm sorry I'm sorry hold on hold on
let me fix myself all right
oh still mocks it can't do it can't do
it J can't do it natural I was so
wrapped up in the show I forgot the plug
that is oh it's like I'm looking at
myself in the mirror and I look great G
re Nation shop.com get this awesome
shirt get that awesome shirt this one
this awesome shirt all designed by re
real reject couple in partnership with
others but for the most part design
ourselves so thank you guys so much cuz
it is
the personal most favorite way to
support the Chanel and I mean that from
the bottom of the heart thank you to all
I bought one uh you look good when you
do it too and they feel comfortable we
make sure to chew shirts that actually
feel comfortable someone with a hairy
body I care about a comfortable
shirt uh what time is it we are up
against the clock and no one else's all
right all right Coy seems like you got a
lot to say so we got two more episodes
to go through but Coy take it away brief
because I know we have more to go
through uh I do think this show is pce
better than a lot of the Marvel shows it
feels like an early Marvel movie for me
pacing wise uh as far as trusting in the
supporting characters and letting the
actual Universe breathe I'm really
enjoying some of the comic elements
where it feels like New York is just
over here causing all of this problem
and it's and it's like leaking into her
town and that's why I I sense like
Kingpin was the next logical thing to
come to the town because now you've you
got to level up you've had the henchmen
come to the you have problem looming
henchmen come to the town Kingpin
himself you have Kingpin stop something
coming there and then that's going to
escalate into the third Act of the show
which I feel like is what we're getting
to now It's Tricky with five episodes
instead of six but I do feel like we're
approaching the third act now that we've
had the second act incident of the
Bonnie making her more humanized so I
really do feel like this is structured a
lot like Series this feels like a comic
book six issue Arc or like a trade
paperback so it's really beautifully
done to not only make New York a
character that's a for boing element
keeping the Kingpin and Daredevil
element over here but they're using the
chronology of years of TV and years of
movies and all of these elements of
dared Kingpin to really build out Ekko
in a way where she feels independent and
New York feels independent
simultaneously but she like a good
Avenger movie can pop in and out of the
main story so I'm I'm in love with the
World building they're doing here this
feels a lot more like genv versus the
boys where it feels like different
perspectives in a universe that can
coexist and cohabitate a world by having
it set in Oklahoma so all of those
elements plus the fight choreography
really leveling up not loving all the
editing around the fight there was a
moment where they had the fight end and
they had to have time pass they're like
cut to ski ball and I was like but
overall what they've done is allow a
world to breathe in the way that I
wanted the shows to where you could
build a character up on television long
form bring them into the movie and you'd
care about them if you've seen the show
but you'd still care about them in the
movie and I think Ekko being a a
spotlight it being a darker show being
our rated does give me hope for
Daredevil and kinin going forward to
allow that tone to have Hell's Kitchen
perhaps be R-rated have Deadpool be
R-rated have blade have Ghost Rider but
that doesn't sacrifice the stock price
by having pg3 M so I really really was
impressed yeah no I I enjoyed this a lot
too I like the progression very much I I
appreciate especially based on what we
said last episode that that was kind of
Maya in her element whereas this takes
her into a place where her element has
bled over onto the people in her life
and is you know impossible to contain to
this like isolated operation and that is
bringing in just yeah more uh
interesting character interactions and
stuff like that uh whether it be with uh
Bonnie or with Oh Black Crow uh them
teaming up finally after everything I
thought was really nice and like well
earned and developed and all that stuff
and uh yeah The Supporting Cast
continues to be great and it's one of
those things where even when like I I
appreciate something like this in a
constructive sense because yeah there
are times where like oh it's a bit of a
funky shot are like oh that was a weird
cut but they feel in line with you know
actual people crafting a Thing versus
like oh this was just Frankenstein
together and that's why it feels weird
it's like okay yeah maybe you had to
figure something out on set or maybe
something didn't go 100% as you hoped it
would but in a weird way it still felt
pretty unified within that and so yeah
it's like even with little Nicks and
things I feel like yeah it's only been
kind of developing and progressing and
now I just hope that in these last two
episodes you know we can get a couple
things that are emotionally resonant in
some kind of you know particularly
gripping or touching way to go along
with all the cool stuff and to make all
the action you know more meaningful
because they have like all the other
stuff and I'm really again enjoying the
development and yeah if they can just
continue pushing those character beats
to the Forefront alongside all the other
know cool stuff and like especially
having Wilson fist come back with that
you know that presence and that sense of
like when he calls the guys off that
sends a message of its own but for him
to show up like I love the even just the
Nuance suggested by that of this guy who
is still very committed to his father
figure role in this person's life
despite the mess of their relationship
here and now and I'm excited for I I
mean I could even see the next episode
being like kind of isolated to the two
of them or something which could be neat
but uh but yeah I'm really excited for
whatever comes next to finish this all
off yeah I agree with both the things
you guys said hey you guys win yeah yes
we win the whites win it we win this
review off oh God and the and the film
Styles too it's so pretty I I think this
Loki and like you mentioned what if
those three have really shown like a
filmmaker you guys are really great for
letting me what you thinke I was just
commending you one of the things you I
was trying to throw that to you because
you were so enthralled at the of the
episode with the whole interlude and the
and the film
style I was trying to I was trying to
shovel past I was going to give him
another tangent but he didn't want my P
up he didn't want my te as you had said
I I really like the making and I'm going
to keep cutting you off because I'm
colonizing your
opinion
Greg it's okay it's okay guys just
trying to get some sympathy points is it
working I'm so turnable this is my you
my sociopath
com I've entered sociopath entered
sociopath here this is it right here I
will belittle or look for sympathy I
will Gaslight you in every possible way
I can do it we had a coming uh no what
are you guys talking about I don't know
your turn the film Styles the prologue I
got nothing really to contribute now
stylistically mysticism it's okay guys
it's okay um well what I would add into
the conversation mix is the the
representation of the chock top people I
I don't know what the proper words are
to say I'm always like every time I talk
about some a a a race of people or a
culture of people that I am not educated
on always questioning am I saying the
right vocabulary to support my
statements here so I'm just going to
hopefully everyone recognizes my
intention here in case I get a word or
two off here it's the
engines okay is it no this is definitely
not
that Nation chakon Nation yeah he said
Eng he did he did with that hard J yep I
N J
us hard J proud of that joke
like that's great y AR
J we got to remember that funny um we
got to remember that for the next one
yeah the next risky sical joke about a
whole nation of people best way to use a
joke is rep people kicked the most
throughout our country's
history a little more while they're we
got a new opportunity for ComEd can we
profit a joke off these people because
they haven't suffered enough this satire
is important this is very
necessary this funny as like I knew J
was just making a joke love how he
responded sincerely when I said is it
don't let that brilliant brilant that's
why camera is here that's why we do
shows together guys capture you have
amazing maack fruit throwing me like a
very ridiculous request in like the tone
of your voice I'll be like sure I I
guess I'll entertain
this this can only go well for me I must
have missed something I guess I'll take
a look
anyway uh yeah like uh I I feel like the
the vibe
of of uh of the Chaka Nation just
literally permeates throughout the
entire presence of like the voice of the
show the voice of of the the the look uh
the mood that evokes from the just the
look and the
atmosphere whether that be present day
or past it's kind of like the
culmination of past and present which is
what the show is doing from its um what
would you call it like the
pro opening acts uh what are those
called in the show inst structurally I
forget like like opening like cold open
or cold open yeah button or something
yes whatever it's called but yeah the
cold open before the credits Ru that
section which usually delves into the
past of the chock to people and then as
we go through the present day story with
Maya
Lopez and then but then you you're
cutting around to like her family and
everyone and just the like the people in
Oklahoma of today I I think that when
they when they spoke about that with
being part of the representation of the
show often times when we talk about
representation and being included in
there sometimes like the handling of
that is is
usually feels repres ping yeah usually
it feels pandering we got one guy or or
you could feel a little bit of force
like it it feels completely natural here
like it seems like the intent of that is
it's it feels like that is the act like
one of the actual purposes of the show
is to let that be part of the voice and
and its character and so I think the way
they have been executing that has been
absolutely excellent and it is one of
the things that I gravitate towards most
when experiencing this show even when I
experience like certain shortcomings
there is that uniqueness that this show
has that separates itself from a lot of
just television shows in general you
know like I'm gr gr there like some
other shows out there I haven't seen
reservation dogs which is not thean
Nation you know uh but there's you know
it's it's not it's not like the
grittiest thing it's gritty for Marvel
sure but so I understand that uh so is
it pushing boundaries I don't know if
it's like pushing boundaries but it it
feels more mature I would still say that
it's it definitely feels much more M
this doesn't feel like you're the one
you sit down and watch with the family
nor has it necessarily gone to VI to the
point where I'm like wow this some of
the edgiest [__]
seen nothing's got into like Netflix
terrain yet um it's like between Marvel
and Netflix it's like a nice radient
honestly I think like you freaking Ethan
Hawk stepping on glass Sho is still like
more uh offputting than anything else
we've seen here so far right um but that
was like the opening of the show uh but
from what we've been getting so far yeah
I think it's been really strong and
and if the lot of its strengths I feel
are outweighing it's uh things that I
might not particularly find to be as
strong I don't know if I'd call it a
weakness per se like there are are
elements where I do feel like I could be
more like
emotionally you're waiting for it to
transcend I'm I'm interested but I'm
never quite
like truly moved or gripped you know
like at the end of day it's a moving
picture at the end of day it is supposed
to be and that's the point of
Storytelling cuz there is a coldness
which is intentional um but I do love
the things I'm loving I'm really loving
that's that's the thing about it that
that is outweighing some of the parts
that there normally this emotional
experience thing that I'm I'm touching
on it's usually a massive deterrence for
me and it's not quite a mass of
deterrence for me here because there's
so many other things that's giving me
that I'm really liking a lot that I'm
ating a different kind of emotional
experience from if that makes does that
make any sense what I'm trying to say
yeah and and anything that this is
falling short on it's still giving you a
whole bunch of things that you can point
at and go like hey given some of the
bumps in the recent Marvel Road please
continue going down this
direction instincts are good to follow
yeah I don't understand the the bad word
of mouth that came out before it because
of the outweighing of so much good well
I could potentially see it becoming a
secret Invasion thing whereas where it's
like the poers get overwheling yeah I
mean like oh this is like really like
serious and focused I see you're saying
but it's got nothing the last couple
episodes it starts to rush
and don't really give a [__] is Echo
going to become like overpowered with
chakon nation mysticism [__] by the end
you know she kills King P like how crazy
is it going to get takes out Daredevil
he's obvious not going to kill Kingman
he's in the Daredevil show so and will
there be a meaningful use for the in
like I like including all of the history
and all of the the the notes of the
nation and whatnot but is there going to
be a personal reason for doing that
Beyond just explaining a Celestial power
set yeah that's cuz cuz yeah like her
there are moments where she seems like
she's opening up to when he gives her
the the new prosthetic leg and he makes
a big deal out of like this is
representative of your culture part of
me was like well she's kind of detached
from it and maybe that could be part of
her journey but uh but yeah like it
would be nice to be a little bit more
plugged into her personal journey
through these images and these you know
flourishes of history and I think we
will hopefully if it lands get there to
the point where like those imagery
because a lot of the imagery in the Mac
David Ma's art with her is important
like actual symbols tie into the
character a lot in the comic books so
I'm really hoping we get to the point
where like a lot of that imagery does
come into play and I think that the
first thing I saw with that was like
okay this might be the connection
between the imagery and the character so
I'm hoping that's where we get and maybe
that yeah maybe she doesn't get imbued
with like a complete cosmic power set
but maybe she has some attenuation to
that and maybe some ability to kind of
tap into or harmonize with it we should
rap without Greg to be we should rap
without because I think we should before
he gets back the inmates taking over the
Asylum leave a like on the video we're
done with this show before he got back
thanks guys your PCT the day shout
out Gabriel welcome to 2024 my friend W
it is uh January so I have to Fathom
what your New Year's resolution is going
to be and if I know you Gabriel and I
think I do I think you do I think I do
it is to buy a b day oh I was going to
make a baptism joke but you beat me to
it baptize your bum my friend change
your life with with a nice jet of warm
soothing cleansing water because here's
the thing Gabriel I need you to be my
guinea pig this year every time I go to
someone's house and then they want to
show off that like hey we got a bouet in
here I'm always like cool I have never
used one cuz I don't get how it works I
don't understand where the water's
coming from where it's shooting from I
don't get how any of it works Gabriel my
mind thinks that it's just shooting up
from the bottom of the toilet of
something that's been used already and
I'm like that's disgusting how is that
that's unhygienic I don't know what's
happening there and so Gabriel I'm going
to need you to buy one tell me what the
process is like send video archive
footage if possible otherwise you're
going to get multiple angles you're
going to get a bunch of jokes about
being an atheist again or uh you know be
being Angel Gabriel or some [__] because
you did not send me video footage of how
they were show us your butt we want to
see your butt and we want to see it your
butt on a bedet we want to see and and
send us some of the water too just you
know once you're done with it John
please now we going to get demonetized
you're too graphically direct I'm sorry
I mean you know just you don't
understand how to around these bapti
baptize your cheeks my friend pray pray
to this hygienic anyway happy New Year
wash your
butt